un deuxième pas positifs du gouvernement
harper en alberta
a été la diminution des taxes et des
impôts
les gens ici apprécie beaucoup de la
situation les éléments négatifs c'est
sûr que les nains les relations
internationales ont été
modifiées par ses agissements le canada
a perdu un peu son image de devait de la
paix et aussi les relations avec les
provinces sont un peu plus difficiles
même si les relations peut-être autant
qu'au québec où commencer par celui mais
c'est sa plus difficile les situations
lawn avec ce gouvernement là et au sujet
des emblèmes du canada c'est certain que
le drapeau aussi très fort et est
commise enfin mon nom explique et
l'hymne national est très important
aussi qui est chanté pratiquement chaque
jour à l'école la mise en fait